中大胆周报
我们历经台股真的有回测
不过回测月线的那一天
拉了一个脚
让大家不免问
这样回测算够了吗
因为随即又反攻
创了一个反弹高
在这个位阶上中大胆要给我什么样的叮咛呢
8月份我相信投资朋友到目前为止
只剩下一天就要收8月份的
我想相信8月份投资朋友应该会感觉到
冷暖的变化非常大
怎么说呢
我记得7月底8月初的时候
你很担心这个台股会不会跌破4万点
然后来到3万6
因为我听到房间有一些声音
然后你就很恐慌
然后那时候我们大胆跟大家提到过
8月份会有跌升反弹
那至少叫你不要卖
不要那么恐慌
是
到了月中的时候
就是这个月的中间的时候
来到四万
这个四万五四万六的时候
就听到大家有听到四万八的声音出来
然后到了月下旬的时候
就上礼拜
大盘曾经又从四万六左右
又拉回到四万四千多点
然后大家会想一想
这个走势是不是又要下去
然后礼拜五的时候又会打财报的助攻
让大盘指数来到46,500点这附近
所以你会发现你这个月
你会不会觉得你到底是要做多还做空
我相信应该有人这样子
就觉得好像下也下不去上也上不去
但这个区间蛮黏的
所以我们发现我个人的做法还是一样
在原来上网之前提到过
如果拉回到44,000左右的附近的时候
你再把它提高到五成左右
因为投信的成本是差不多在那附近
那上个礼拜有今天来到44,000、210
很接近
那如果有佐料加回合的话
我还是建议在这个46,000以上的话
还是把它持股降低到四成左右
我还是可以讲究
我不会因为大盘的大涨
我马上变乐观
也不会因为大盘大跌马上变悲观
我相信如果你从头到尾再看的话
应该是会知道我待会这样想办
之所以会这么样子的想法
是因为是说
这个月的大盘的成交量是17兆
上个月的成交量是21兆
你刚从21兆跟17兆多来比的话
就差了将近有3兆多
换句话说
这个部分的差异的成交量
我个人认为不会一口金马上就跑上去
所以我个人认为还是需要再做一个整理
这次呢
外资呢
在这个月当中大买
然后呢
投信呢
上个礼拜吧
我记得是历史上的算是
最大卖超
那你看啊
这个就是大买超
一个大卖超
所以我刚才讲的
不是你错觉错乱
连那个法人两边也很错乱
所以我看啊
我发现最近的投信
到了四万六四万五
一样
他买的金额是不多
大概只有几十亿
不是非常高
换句话说
投信他也在评估一个叫做
到底这个行情是马上就会喷涨上去呢
还是说未来会有机会再拉回
所以你们有发现
我真的跟投信的做法是
想法很隐致
比较是投信派
其实到现在
投信的做法跟我现在都是一样
有点在观望整个市场上的状况
因为这次的辉达的财报算不错
贵人认为说4万点应该不容易再失手了
预期未来如果回到稳健区的时候
你再把它提高到六成到八成
那这波
这个礼拜会有修正调整就是
如果拉回到四万二的话
你就可以把它提高到八到九成
之前我还想说
如果你有的话
可能到四万点的时候
你再来做八到九成的一个动作
但是挥打的财报是算是真的不错
而且下个季度的成长率非常高
所以想到四万二左右
你大概就可以把它当作是
未来最差的状况
就是在这个位置
那接下来到九月份
下个月份
馬上就會有一些一個新月份開始那這個位置來講你就要先思考一下这大法来到46,000点左右未来下个月到底是要偏多还偏空
那偏多偏空之前
我们先来看一下
下个月利多跟利空
我大概简单做一个整理的部分
这9月份目前大概看起来
有就是9月初的半导体涨
那这个部分是好像也有
已经是
先前就已經有在做一個反應
當然就要看半導體產
它發揮的效果是如何
那再來就是Apple的星期
有會做一個發表
那這個大部分都是集中在9月的上旬
換句話說如果真耀工
應該會偏向在9月的上旬的部分
那主要重大力多另外一個
就是投信我們剛提到過
8月份它已經把
在高檔已經把一些資金挪出來
那相對為有拉回的時候
它有資金在做低間
如果沒有大幅度拉回
大幅度拉回
他这个笔资金也可以随时在做一个
重新再回头买进
就曾经我们上次在上一集提到过
投信也是有曾经看错过
例如说在1月的过年前的时候
他看错之后马上再买回补
所以我现在就在等这个讯号
如果投信都没有再积极回补的话
我个人认为说这个大盘
或许还有一些机会
再做一个反复整理
那另外来讲就是比较好
就是说
抽码已经有整理一段时间
那毕竟整理一段时间
从7月到目前8月来讲的话
也大概也只有一两个月
我个人觉得还不够久
尤其上次的我们提到过了
上次的1.8兆的日量的部分是借钱来的
是借钱来的
所以呢借钱来的
我个人认为说这个部分
不会那么快就做一个笑话
那当然另外好事就是选举
到了现在位置已经升价
选举已经大概不到三个月时间
当然利空的部分
我认为比较多一点
利空第一个就是
川习会会在9月下旬的部分
那究竟川普跟习近平之间谈的一些东西
坦白讲这个事比较敏感
因为毕竟我们刚好是处在这中间
所以我讲川习会是要注意
再来就是央行利率
第三届李建斯的会议
那这个部分来讲的话就是因为
最近我看到一些很多学者提到过
台湾的CPI已经有段时间都在2%以上
坦白讲物价的虽然目前物价的上涨
稍微有点趋缓
但是毕竟领利息的人真的不够足以支付
这个物价的上涨
所以到底会在这边调涨利率呢
还是会维持不变
就要看央行的态度
因为这一次是在选举前的最后一次
就看央行到底要以哪个角度来看
那当然第三个部分就是日元升息
因为之前高士有曾经有提到过
可能会让日元在9月份做升息
也是一样跟台湾一样
就是物价上涨
如果你觉得台湾有物价通膨的压力
那日本更有
因为什么
日本的东西涨价
它也不会因为说因为区域
也是全球都会涨
但是相对日本的利率是很低
所以他们之间的差距比我们台湾更大
那在第四点就是美国的事务的结算
会在第三季
那这个部分来讲就要看到所有的指数位置
如果相对是高
那相对就可能会有一些结账压力
相对如果是有些拉回来比较属于在低的话
那可能就相对这个部分就会比较不是偏地空的部分
再来第五个就是第三季的作照
我们知道9月份是第三季的下个月份的作帐的部分
到底现在投信或是外资法人
是先来这个位置就见好就收呢
还是呢再持续拿钱来做一个推胜的动作
再来就是外销订单的成长率可能会去缓
我待会再跟各位做说明
那另外一个就是没有新资金的进场
很多投资朋友讲说为什么没有新资金的进场
我觉得没有大钱进来
如果按照过往来讲的话
这个位置如果大家长得很凶的话
应该会常常动不动就见到一兆
那为什么没有常常见到一兆
就表示没有新的资金进来
那没有新资金进来我也觉得合理
奖金都发完了对对对然后呢现金鼓励也是该买的早就买了所以呢现在就剩下那一些电子公司发给科技员工的这种年中
能不能会进来买
再来就是
9月份有低的上涨几率
我们待会就跟各位讲
9月份的行情
我先讲一下
我个人的内容
还会续拉回做低档的整理
我们先讲一下
这10年当中
9月份
是第三季最低的上涨几率
我上次有跟各位提到过
它只有30%
分别是2025、2019、2016
只有这三次
其他都是下跌的机会高
那上次我提到过
8月份容易会跌升反弹
如果你相信上次的数据
那你这次我个人还是认为
我要去相信
7月份呢
过去的两次下跌
就是分别在2024跟2021年
你会发现
7月份两次下跌
9月份就是下跌
到目前为止是有这样的情况
那我们再回退来看一下
过去的这三次9月份的上涨
7月份是怎样
7月份都是上涨
换句话说今年的7月份是跌
所以这个表现不成立
那如果扣除到9月份的极端的上涨
的行情的部分
因为他曾经有最多的是涨6.5
就是去年
不过因为那时候是从对等关税完之后
所以呢这个部分
相对是所谓低基期的部分
那另外还有曾经有跌过
2020跌破跌过11%
如果扣掉这个话
大概就是跌幅
落在3.18%到正的2%左右
再一个另外就是
这事实上要有关注
9月份如果上涨
那一定会超越8月份的上涨
就是我们过去看的
2025跟2019、2016
你会发现9月份上涨
一定会超过8月份的上涨幅度
那8月份的上涨幅度
如果就我们目前来看的话
就是以8月24号我来做统计
如果是以45224来算的话
大概涨幅是4.88
那么就有机会挑战47431
730就是挑战488啦
那因为还有一天
还有一个交易
所以最后8月份的涨跌幅是如何
我们讲就到时候再看
但是如果用45000多点来算的话
它是有机会来挑战47431
但我的前提是
那要表示一定要够强
那你够强的话
才有机会来挑战
这个47000到48000这个位置
那这时候我会保守是因为
我个人认为说
S&P500的部分
在近100年当中
你可以从这个图上可以看出来
从1月到12月份
眼睛一看就知道
一年度当中
唯一下跌的就是9月份
平均的跌幅是1.2%
其他都是平均的
都是呈现上涨
而且呢从7月到8月到9月
它是逐渐涨幅是慢慢缩小
所以你到底要去9月份
这个12个月份当中
是最不好的行情当中去
期待更强的操作呢
还是宁可等9月份如果押回来
在期待后面的10月份
11、12还有明年的1月2月的行情
我个人会评想如果是这样的话
那我认为4万6千多点
本来就是我认为比较大的压力用位置
如果呢
这个位置有再压回来
举个例子
到了9月中或到了9月中下群
我个人觉得如果真的压不回来到很低的话
到时候我们再会去把指数做调整
而且各位可能有很少会注意到一个事情就是
台积电跟美光
这是自家很家公司
应该是我们台股很重要的观察重点公司
但是你会发现台积电ADR
我少见可以看到
它竟然出现两个向下跳空缺口
过去台积电ADR或美光出现向下跳空缺口
不是没有
但是要在低档出现两个向下跳空缺口
那不一定会马上着落
但是至少表示什么
有可能是会压抑到多头力道
我们就美光的走势来讲
美光最近也出现两个向下跳空缺口
那你会发现
在今年的6月底到7月初的时候
它也曾经出现两个向下跳空缺口
後來有曾經回到737.88塊錢這個位置
換句話說最近在自已線附近
也出現兩個向下跳空缺口這也就是為什麼說你會發現外資在這個禮拜五的时候有把华王店这些相关的地略的记忆点的部分有稍微做调节
因为这两家公司很少会看到
有两个跳空缺口向下的
所以我觉得这块的部分
你可以再多观察一下
他们的走势是如何
那再来另外一个就是
再来就看这个外销订单
7月份的外销订单
YOY是61.9
比6月份的59.4来得高
但现在大家就去看8月份跟未来的9月份
按照市场之前的经济部这边所提的
8月份的营收可能
8月份预计会在971到991美元
年车会落在61.4到64.8
我个人认为应该偏向在区间的下減
为什么
大家有没有注意到
8月初台币对美元的部分是32块半
到了8月底的时候
已经来到31块半
一个月当中
台币都升值得快
对美元快升值一块钱
相对的升值幅度是将近2%
光这个2%
就让外资在8月份台币的汇率的部分
至少他赚了将近快2%的差价的部分
再另外台股呢
8月份的指数上涨将近有7.44%
将近这两个加起来
就将近快有9.多个%的幅度
如果你是一个外资
你在这边会稍微见好就收呢
还是呢
持续在做获利的推升
我个人认为是
一个月要赚10%
坦白讲也不常见的
我个人认为说
如果是这样的话
那么未来获取台币
有可能会再贬回去
我个人会这样
因为你从32块半
升到31块半
现在刚好就是
外销出口的旺季
如果9月份再给它升下去
那7、8、9是出口的旺季
将近两个月都在做升值的话
那对出口商的业力
这个利润会相当大影响
姑且不论未来的公布的成绩单是如何
光是在下个月
9月10号公布的月的营收的部分
我认为可能会不如市场上
原先各商规公司所一起的营业的变化
因为对美元的升值幅度是稍微有点高一点
如果是这样的话我们来算一下
因为去年8月份的外销订单
大概是六百亿美元
如果用這樣的情況來算這個幅度的話
大概就是62%
那62%跟上個月的YOY
就大概61.9大概就趨緩
那去年的9月份是702億
那假如說用1000億來算的話
那YY就變成42.4
也就是從6成變成4成多
那如果達到62%以上
那大概要達到1140億左右
看起來目前的我個人認為說
我比较偏向
这个营收YY
应该是比较偏向是趋缓
如果营收YY是比较偏趋缓
那这个台股在9月份
就没有必要会马上创新高
可能应该会跟着这个YY的角度
会比较偏向是来回去间的震荡整理
所以我想大概对整个行情的走势
我可以认为说9月份
宁可你可以去乐观去请待未来行情
但是呢
你还不得不要小心谨慎
那因为时间有限
我待会会在我们银山满当中
会跟各位来报告一下
整个第三季的部分
事实上它还是有一些行情的一个重点的key point
可以留意
好 因为好戏在后头
因为我们有看到其实历年的第四季
行情的状况都是越走越好的
所以也蛮期待说
后面要创新高的机会一定是有的
但9月可能有一些关卡
我们还是得把它度过去
那中大胆常常会觉得
与其在这个时候冲冲冲
不如保留一些资金
保留一些子弹
到了第四季好做的时候
我们顺势来做哦
那同样的如果认同我们的理念
也欢迎订阅我们的VIP
VIP很多人在问
每个月是每个月750块钱
那是在每一个礼拜天跟礼拜一的晚上六点钟
我们会有影片做上架
除了当周我们会讲一下
到底要推荐什么样的股票
也会回顾之前推过的股票
帮大家持续做追踪
因为很多人好奇到底内容是什么
好 那我们今天的节目就到这边了
那我会把订阅的连结放在留言的第一则
我们在VIP见啰